grip6 manufactures amazing belts
wallets and wool socks and did you know
they have unlimited replacements for
life
check out their chest themed merchandise
at grip6.com
chess and use code chest 20 for 20 off
your next order
everybody it's grand master ben feingold
here with the game of the day with
trust.com
um for the candidates event which is
ongoing i'll be doing the game of the
day
after the round um it'll be a relatively
quick analysis of the game
it won't be one of my typical three or
four hour videos so
it'll be short and sweet um today's game
of the day
was very easy to pick um it was the game
between caruana
and mvl mvo was tied for first
with the pognyacci going into the round
and caruana was a point back
so i mean they had over a year to
prepare for this game
and they did so we'll get to the really
critical points
of which there were about ten very
exciting game
which it took almost six and a half
hours to finish
so they played the night or sicilian
which is what mvl
likes to play and uh
sometimes people who don't want to play
a million moves of theory they'll play
you know bishop b5 check
but okay fabiano likes to play william
who's a theory
so this is a big theoretical valley um
battle
because um probably the two best
prepared players in the world in the
night or
probably right here so okay now
in this position white can play every
move and every move has been played
even moves that you think look
ridiculous they've probably been played
for white
um so it's hard to prepare for black
because
when you have the black pieces you have
to be ready for everything which mvl is
so bishop g5 which is the old main line
f4 and now um
black can play bishop e7
and queen c7 and knight beat e7 and b5
um which is the old main line or you
could play the poison pawn
with queen b6 um which is even more
interesting
so he chose queen b6 queen d2
takes on b2 and this is the poison pawn
variation
which has been played for probably about
70 years
um almost every top grand master in the
world
has had either white or black in this
position the two main moves here are f5
and e5
f5 is more popular but e5 is becoming
the main move now
so he played e5 black can take or play
h6 uh
mvl has played h6 before and
uh this is the main line of the e5 h6
line
so this is that they just started
playing the main moves
um so this has all been prepared for
over a year by both players
queen takes a2 rook d1 so white
sacrificing all of his pawns
and black's only moving his queen so
it depends what kind of style you like
do you like being three or four pawns up
or do you like developing your pieces
and castling and
depends what your style is and the the
point of this
is this is the candidates you must win
the tournament
and this is a lot different than other
tournaments okay
coming in second isn't better than
coming in eighth
last place if you want to play for the
world championship
you have to come in first that means if
you go draw a draw a draw draw
you don't come in first so this is a
great opening for both players
because it's likely somebody is going to
win because it's such a double-edged
position
um white has a big attack white has a
big lead in development
and black's always up a lot of pawns so
active interesting players like this
kind of game
okay queen d5 attacking the knight on e4
again this is all the main line
queen e3 uh queen takes e5
and mvl has played all this before with
black now
this position there is about a 200 grand
master games
and in almost all of them white played
bishop e2
which you know prepares to castle gets
his last piece developed
and the novelty which um
is very hard to prepare for because the
engine
immediately doesn't say this is great if
you have your engine on for
a month then it probably says it's good
is the move c3
that's never been played before and
if you put it on your engines it says
yes e3
but you know if you analyze it for a
year
with different engines with your seconds
you might come to a different conclusion
okay and mvl
i don't think he possibly could have
known the move c3 it's never been played
before and it's sort of weird
okay so bishop c5 was played this the
engine likes this move
pins the knight threatens to castle etc
bishop g3 attacking the queen queen d5
is not only force but it's an excellent
move keeps pressure on the position
and this is the point of the novelty
so c3 is sort of a boring move but he
he had envisioned that this would happen
fabiano probably amongst
many other things and he played bishop
c4 sacrificing his bishop
again the engine doesn't like this move
and probably if you let the engine think
about it for you know a day or two it
probably would like the move
but and i'm sure that fabiano and his
team you know
looked at this for quite a long time you
have to take the bishop
and now bishop to d6 that's the point
the bishop on c5 is attacked
um black cat castle
and if black takes the bishop knight
takes forks the king and queen
if it was white's move and he took the
bishop and black took back with the
knight
knight d6 check still forks the king and
queen the king and queen are in
prime forking position now the engine
after thinking i put this on like four
different engines
after thinking for five minutes
four minutes three minutes wants to play
bishop d4
and it likes black's position now from a
human perspective
giving up this bishop and leaving this
bishop on d6
and you could never castle that doesn't
seem right so for a human
bishop takes d4 is really hard to play
you don't want to give up that bishop
you don't want to leave the bishop on d6
forever and i'm sure
there's tons of analysis done by the
fabiano team
on bishop takes d4 since the engine
likes it you know without
thinking too long okay he played the
other move the engine says is okay
knight f6 that threatens the knight
so you have to play uh knight take c5
you can't take with the bishop because
the bishop's only defended by the knight
and
black just takes the knight so you have
to play knight takes c5
knight d5 attacks the queen queen e5 is
the only move
and i'm sure this was prepared by
fabiano
but mvl is just making it up uh you can
play queen takes c3 check but the engine
actually prefers
rook g8 which is what mvl played and now
it says white only has one move but
again
this is fabiano's preparation and a lot
of the super gms
think this is like the best preparation
of the year or the best preparation of
all time
or something i mean they really liked
what fabiano was doing
okay so he played knight d takes e6
and he's gonna crush that king takes
takes
and uh the move that makes the most
sense
is the move that mvl played but he also
could have played king f1
which i'm sorry king f7 which is also
possible
and uh knight f6 is also possible
but i can't imagine a human playing that
and i'm sure fabiano is prepared for
that
mvl made the most logical move trading
queens
so his king doesn't get checkmated and
they traded queens
and mvl's up a lot of material
a lot but his rook on a8 is going to get
captured
but he's have so much material it's
still about equal
king f7 you could also play king d7
which again i don't think a human would
play
you don't want to take the rook now
because this rook is attacked
so rip d3 attacking the knight the
knight moves to safety
we castle with check
we take the rook i'm guessing this is
probably the end
of fabi's preparation for this
particular variation
and we're on move 28. um it's possible
the prep ended earlier but i doubt it
i think he saw this position over the
last year
the engine says it's equal but it's
easier to play white
because the past pawns aren't very
dangerous they're right there
and white's rooks look pretty good the
king is a little unsafe
black is totally uncoordinated so i
think humans would want to have white
here
but the engine says it's okay for black
okay
then they just played normal chess that
wasn't prep
just standard normal stuff
and uh
fabiano got to mess up uh
mvl's pawns by giving up his beautiful
bishop
but the ruined pawn structure is worth
it now white's playing for a win
he gets lift for his king and these
pawns are weak
this king is open and these pawns
they're just not dangerous yet
if they were further advanced then maybe
black's better
but since they're not going to queen and
black's king is in trouble
the rook's better than the knight
there's two isolated weak pawns
white has the advantage here okay
and eventually that's that's a nice move
because the f pawns pinned
they eventually got down
to a position there was a table based
position
a seven piece table base okay
and it's this position um this is a
seven
piece table-based position uh
wait is this it no no i'm sorry later i
apologize okay
this is a seven piece table based
position the table base says it's a draw
but it's very difficult to draw for
black black has to wind his way
and even by losing the a pawn he's still
drawing
and he's going to lose the a pawn in the
long run he can't hold on to it
and this is a drawn position according
to the table base but
i mean it's not not easy you're down the
exchange for nothing and
in this position uh this is this is the
key position number one
the only move that draws according to
the table base
is knight f5 and he played knight f5
and magnus was like really impressed
because nvl's defending so well
stopping rook g3 check and then very
soon thereafter
he played the move knight h6 which loses
now again this is hard to explain
unless i had about five hours and i read
the table bases and i understood them
but problem is the knight's not very
well placed on on
h6 and you know black is just in zigzag
he can't move his pawn can't move his
king because his knight he has to move
his knight
and it turns out e7 and g7 are safer
squares
giving the knight more leeway and after
check
king f7 yeah that knight's not good on
h6
if it was on e7 or g7 it has a lot of
places to go
okay and once again king e4 is this
zug's long move it's like your move
i dare you to move so that's unfortunate
uh knight g8 rerouting the night that's
you know pretty good
and the way that white wins is
interesting
when i was watching the game i thought
maybe the king would try to come up here
but actually getting the king up here is
better and that's what fabiano did
yeah and eventually his his king you
know black is just always in zigzag
he doesn't want to move his king off of
f7 because then the king just walks in
um so he you know he repeated a lot
he fooled around a lot and this was
funny
um i remember i saw hikaru on chess.com
and he said the the table base says
these moves all win
but this move doesn't he's trying to
figure out why
and the reason is if the rook can go to
the fifth rank
it stops black from doing anything and
after rook d3
97 the rook can't go to the fifth rank
that's actually pretty funny
okay and mvl eventually capitulated
and in this position if he plays king g6
to stop the king from moving in
king h4 is check we defend the nine the
king goes to h5
so once the king gets to h5 it's pretty
easy you just walk on in
and in this position probably early for
a lot of people not for grand masters
black resigned
black is losing here and the engine
that's not very strong
that says white's plus nine in like
three seconds
yeah you can't lose this pawn so
if you play the move 97 uh king f7 wins
the only thing i would do if i was black
instead of resigning
is play knight f4 check that's the only
non-resigning move
then then you could play every move wins
king h6 king f7
it doesn't matter king h6 is the
preferred move right now
uh king e4 the rook goes back
and black is in total zug's one um
you know my king can go to g7 f7 g6
you'll never win my g pawn if you play
f5 i play g5
so it's completely winning now the
engine says plus 55.
so maybe a little early for some people
but after
king g6 mvl resigned it's the game of
the tournament
um mvl did a really good job against the
novelty c3
and the peace sacrifice bishop c4 but he
couldn't draw
the drawn ending because it was very
difficult and obviously
throughout the game he had less time so
fabiano's catching up
thanks for watching the recap of round
eight tomorrow's round nine i'll do a
recap then
hopefully we have a game this exciting
this is grandmaster ben feingold for
chess.com
keep watching our videos on the
candidates watch the candidates live
it's the chess.com twitch page has great
coverage
you should see it's amazing there's a
lot of new stuff going on camera angles
and commentators and
all kinds of stuff see you guys next
time bye everyone
[Music]
you